[Musique]
top départ pour le télescope spatial
james webb l'appareil de la nasa devrait
permettre d'observer l'univers avec une
précision inégalée
il rejoindra le mythique hubble premier
télescope spatial qui en 31 ans a
révolutionné l'astronomie les
astronautes de discovery à pied d'oeuvre
le télescope hubble est déjà dans
l'espace mais il est encore
soigneusement emballé dans la soute de
la navette il ce ne sera largué que
demain le 25 avril 1990 hubble fait son
entrée dans l'espace à 600 km au dessus
de la terre fruit d'une collaboration
entre la nasa et l'agencé spatiale
européenne
le télescope doit ouvrir la voie à une
nouvelle ère de l'astronomie moderne on
sait qu'on va regarder donc le limites
de notre univers des moments où
l'univers était presque en formation
encore donc on va observer des choses
qui sont qui nous raconte notre passé et
nous sommes passés de notre univers ya
15 milliards d'années malgré quelques
problèmes techniques rebelle va
rapidement tenir ses promesses en mai
1990 un mois après sa mise en orbite le
télescope livre sa première image un
amas d'étoilés éloigne et et à karina
c'est son nom est situé à 1260 années
lumière de la terre c'est la première
photographie de l'espace enregistré par
le télescope spatial hubble hier il a
fallu deux heures pour transmettre les
clichés à la terre et une petite heure
de plus pour transformer les données
électroniques en images hubble ne se
contente plus de voir les étoiles il
m'arrivait voir c'est le point de départ
d'une série de milliers de photos du
cosmos au fil des ans hubble va
bouleverser les connaissances en matière
d'astronomie et offrir de grandes
découvertes âges de l'univers existence
de trous noirs ou de planètes
extrasolaires
explosion et mes sens des toiles aurores
boréales aux extrémités de saturne et
surtout un extraordinaire voyage dans le
temps
en plongeant toujours plus profondément
dans le ciel le télescope a permis de
détecter des étoiles forme et il y à
plus de 12 milliards d'années peu de
temps après la naissance de l'univers le
télescope dont la durée de vie était
initialement de 15 ans a connu plusieurs
missions de maintenance des
interventions très délicate qui ont
souvent compromis l'existence de hubble
sa mort a d'ailleurs plusieurs fois été
annoncée
l'espace c'est la mort du télescope
hubble la nasa annoncé qu'elle
suspendait la maintenance de hubble va
bientôt tirer sa révérence le télescope
spatial hubble devrait être à la
retraite depuis des années pourtant unis
continue de nous fournir des images de
l'espace absolument extraordinaire
humble résiste dans les étoiles après
une panne en octobre dernier il a encore
une fois repris du service jusqu'à ce
que le télescope james webb viennent
prendre le relais
[Musique]